"Cobra Kai" might be all about the karate wars,
but it has more in common with body slams and
suplexes than anyone could have imagined.
One of the most monumental Terry Silver
scenes in "Cobra Kai" Season 4 is his ruthless
deal with rejected Cobra Kai student Stingray.
After Silver beats Stingray up and sets up John
Kreese to take the fall, the millionaire alone is
in control of the Cobra Kai dojo. In Season 5, we
find out that Stingray received bragging rights,
Terry-enforced Cobra Kai respect, and a
sweet material compensation for his role
in the betrayal. As the season proceeds,
it becomes clear that Stingray's cool new
crib and even cooler new ride haven't been
able to extinguish the burning shame that
hides underneath his confrontational demeanor.
Kreese might be in prison, but he's intent on
proving that he's innocent -- and, as always, he
isn't above using underhanded tactics to achieve
his goals. Knowing that Daniel LaRusso and his
allies wouldn't give him the time of day if he
contacted them, Kreese enlists Tory Nichols to
give Daniel a nameless tip about the situation.
Desperate to get a win over Terry, Daniel
decides to pay Stingray a visit. When the
controversial Cobra Kai student eventually makes
an appearance, he's behind the wheel of the cool
Cobra Kai Dodge Challenger that used to belong
to Johnny, rocking out to "Judas" by Fozzy.
The hard-rocking song about becoming a Judas is an
extremely good fit for the traitorous character,
who blasts it on full volume and sings along to
the lyrics. However, as it so often does, "Cobra
Kai" adds some seriously dark undercurrents and
deeper meanings in this deceptively simple scene.
In fact, Stingray's new "theme song"
just so happens to mean much more than
you'd initially assume and alludes
to his rise and fall in the series.
Having the show's biggest Judas character rocking
out to a song called "Judas" is pretty obvious,
but there is a twist. The Judas in the song's
lyrics is absolutely horrified of what he's done,
and hopes to find a way to right his wrongs. This
telegraphs Stingray's deep regret for his actions,
and his eventual redemption in the season
finale. As the chorus of the song goes:
"What have I become, now that I've
betrayed / Everyone I've ever loved,
I pushed them all away / And I have been a slave
to the Judas in my mind / Is there something left
of me to save in the wreckage of my life."
These few lines sum up Stingray's "Cobra
Kai" Season 5 arc in an eerily
efficient fashion, as he comes
to feel the exact same way about his actions.
Don't think that the song's hidden meanings end
there, though. The singer of Fozzy is none other
than Chris Jericho, the famed pro wrestler who
works with All Elite Wrestling, and uses "Judas"
as his entrance theme. This isn't Jericho's first
time in the "Cobra Kai" limelight. The man himself
has thanked the show for a name drop in Season 3,
Episode 6. Jericho also seems to be on good terms
with Martin Kove. The actor has appeared as a
guest on Jericho's "This Is Jericho" podcast,
and he's also turned up on "AEW Dynamite"
as wrestler Dr. Britt Baker's sensei.
The lighter moments of "Cobra Kai" and
professional wrestling scratch a pretty similar
itch, so they seem like a pretty natural match.
Since "Cobra Kai" Season 5 only strengthens
Jericho's ties to the show, it could be just
a matter of time before the hard-rocking wrestler
appears on the show in the flesh. Perhaps he could
turn up as a rival sensei in the grand tournament
of the hopefully inevitable "Cobra Kai" Season 6?